So Donald Trump is very worried about the
attention that the d.E.A, the DNC, the Democratic
National Convention is going to get this week.
And one of the things they're doing is having
campaign advisers kind of manage expectations,
their float.
Trump campaign advisers are floating the idea
that Joe Biden might get an eight to ten point
bump this week from the DNC.
Now, that's extremely unlikely.
But the idea is if they say Biden could get
eight to 10, when Biden gets three or four,
which is typical from a convention, they can
say, oh, no, Biden underperformed.
Nobody likes him.
We expected him to get eight to 10 points,
but he only got three or four.
So they're doing that.
Trump's flying to multiple cities this week
to do rally like events, which we'll be covering
separately.
So I won't spend a ton of time on that right
now.
And in addition to this, Donald Trump is also
doing a bunch of interviews.
He's doing a bunch of press.
And he started off the week on Fox and Friends
again.
And it went really badly.
Before we start with the politics.
I want to start with the strangest moment.
Donald Trump's younger brother, Robert Trump,
tragically passed away over the weekend in
his early 70s. Trump, of course, struggles
to show any emotion or human connection.
Asked about it.
His Trump says they say Robert was my best
friend, which is really weird language to
use about your supposed best friend and brother.
Take a look at this bizarre video.
Listen, you know, a lot of people have been
thinking about you and your family over the
weekend.
I knew you were able to get to the hospital
before your brother Robert died here in New
York City.
We are so sorry for your loss.
Well, I appreciate it.
It was not not a great weekend.
It's very hard.
You knew it was going to happen.
But still, when it happens, it's a very tough
day.
He was a great guy.
He was a tremendous guy.
You know, he was my friend.
I guess they say best friend.
And that's true.
And, you know, losing him is not easy.
David Pakman, that is really, really strange
language.
I guess they say he was my best friend.
And that's that's I guess that's true.
What I think is that the statement that was
put out by the White House quoting Trump,
saying he was my best friend, Trump didn't
really write it.
And Trump didn't really say it.
So when Trump says they say he was my best
friend, he really means the people who wrote
the statement attributing that quote to me.
They said he was my best friend and I guess
he sort of was.
And then lastly, Trump is asked again about
his late brother, Robert Trump.
And Trump sort of eulogy was about Trump,
wasn't Robert Trump wasn't jealous of my success.
And he thought he was a great president.
Like it's all about Trump, if you can believe
that he was loyal people.
There was no jealousy.
You know, a lot of times in families, I hate
to say it, but there's jealousy and especially
among children and among children that are
competitive children is because he was very
competitive.
There was not an ounce of jealousy.
He'd go around talking about how great this
is for the country and it's so incredible.
And then he was my biggest fan.
People would tell me all the time I spoke
to your brother and your brother was always
so thrilled and so thrilled at what was happening
and what was happening for the country was
he was so angry with China because of what
happened, where the plague came in and they
shouldn't have allowed it to happen.
They could have stopped it.
He was so upset by that.
There was he couldn't more than people would
be upset.
A lot of people have already forgotten and
you can't forget.
But he was a fantastic guy.
Well, we're very sorry for your loss.
And, well, thanks.
Asked about his brother.
Who died two days earlier?
Trump says he was loyal to me.
He wasn't jealous of all of my great success.
He was mad at China because of the plague
and he thought I was doing a great job.
This is not a person with normal emotion or
with normal emotional connections to others.
So that's out of the way.
Let's now get into the political stuff.
Trump again, just insisting everything's fine
with the virus and says without his border
wall, which Mexico was going to pay for but
didn't, and which he was going to build across
the entire U.S. Mexico border.
But didn't, he says without that border wall,
things would be much worse.
Which is ridiculous.
Take a look.
What a while.
But can I ask you something about you that
you should let it be an office?
Because we would have right now the plague
coming in.
Like, you know, those 280 miles I built have
stopped like hundreds of thousands of people.
Mexico is heavy, heavy covered territory.
They're highly inflected vectors.
I built the wall and that wall to stop people
from coming in.
If she said that, I know Sleepy Joe said it,
he said we should stop the wall and I might
even tear down the way he wants to tear down
a wall.
That's the best border wall ever built in
terms of the success of it.
So you really hear that manic energy from
Trump shot out of a cannon, as I say.
And to add some facts to this.
Trump says if it weren't for his 280 miles
of wall, which is like nothing, by the way,
we would have hundreds of thousands of additional
cases coming in from Mexico.
The numbers just don't bear this out.
No.
One, in total cases, Mexico has 10 percent
of the cases that we do.
Now, Mexico has fewer people.
That's true.
So per capita, the U.S. is eigth in cases.
And Mexico is 57.
That's per capita.
Now, that can depend on testing.
Well, in the U.S., we are tenth in deaths
per capita.
Mexico is 13th in deaths per capita.
So it's a complete fantasy world.
Fox and Friends allows it completely uncritically.
Then Trump starts to insist that the world
is calling him because he's so good at dealing
with Turkish President Erdogan.
Nobody knows how to deal with Erdogan other
than Trump.
Trump tuning his own horn here.
Take a look.
At me if they need help with Turkey.
The heads of countries.
Last week they called me up.
Could you call her the one?
I said, why?
P.S.
You're the only one that he'll listen to.
He doesn't listen.
Just hear the only one.
Is it?
Is that because the United States is.
No, that's because of you.
That's because your personality.
You're the only one that he will listen to.
What about what?
I don't like saying this publicly, but it
happens to be true.
I get along with him and he listens and is
this may be the most narcissistic thing that
we've heard Donald Trump say.
Then then Trump compares the Taliban to the
hosts of Fox and Friends interviewing him
in this interview.
This is weird reconstituting in Afghanistan,
though, and you couldn't.
If you look at her issues, you couldn't be
more different.
Think about Brian is there reconstituting.
I'll take him out.
But we had at least had at one point one hundred
more than one hundred thousand soldiers.
That's ridiculous.
And we're ready to do whatever we have to
do.
We're dealing with the Taliban.
I said, look, let me tell you something.
And I've dealt with him directly.
These are tough people.
They're like you people.
Maybe not that tough, but you know what?
These are tough people.
They said, look, if you play games, we're
going to come in.
We're going to hit you harder than any country
in the history of the world has ever been.
It.
I guess maybe for Trump, this counts as adopting
a sense of humor.
I don't even know what's going on.
Trump continues to be unable to pronounce
Kamala Harris his name correctly now.
That may not change.
While he continues to allude to the Joe Biden
dimentia stuff he still can't say.
Kamala's name.
Maybe people are going to feel sorry for him
and maybe a win, but our country is too important
for that.
You're dealing with people that are very sharp.
You're dealing with world class chess players,
the leaders of these countries.
I know them.
But we do very well with all of them.
Irda, one of Turkey.
All of you can't have a guy that shot.
You can have a guy that doesn't know where
he is.
You can have a guy that's afraid to leave
his basement because he can't speak any longer.
And by the way, it is best.
He was a good you know, that he was not the
guy.
But but we're not talking about a bad time.
And you can't do that.
You can't feel sorry for him and vote for
him.
Because if that means and Kamala Harris is
going to take over it, she's a disaster.
Look at her positions on everything.
Kamala, of course, is a fictional drug in
the series Battlestar Galactica.
Joe Biden's running mate is Kamala.
Kamala Harris.
Then Trump is asked about people claiming
that he might not leave office if he loses
in November.
And what's amazing about this is Trump doesn't
deny it.
He's asked, well, what about the people saying
you're not?
Going to leave in November.
He just bashes Hillary.
Hillary is not even the person he's running
against this time around.
Mr. President, your reaction?
Well, the first thing I think of is crooked
Hillary Clinton when during one of the debates,
she asked whether or not I would leave office.
Would I accept the results of the election?
Do you remember?
Would you accept the result?
And I gave her a decent answer and agreed.
The problem is she didn't accept it.
She went crazy.
She's still going crazy.
I mean, she's gone nuts.
And so it's so they I mean, they call it Trump
Derangement Syndrome.
I don't know if that's true or not, but it's
certainly close.
I go by the election.
Now, with that being said, I have to tell
you that if you go with this universal mail
and where you send millions of votes in California,
tens of millions of ballots being sent to
everybody and their dogs.
Dogs are getting I'm OK.
Not exactly inspiring confidence that Donald
Trump will leave peacefully again.
I believe he will leave, but I believe he
will do it if he loses by claiming it was
rigged, possibly catalyzing and coalescing
his supporters to real world violence out
in the streets.
I think it could get very, very ugly and we
need to be prepared for that as much as we
need to be prepared for the voter suppression
and everything else that is going on.
Case in point, the post office now says there
are tens of millions of ballots at risk.
And that's what I want to
talk
about next.